buenos días hasta el momento no se
conocen mayores detalles sobre las
causas de la muerte del duque de
edimburgo el príncipe felipe pero lo que
hemos reportado en las últimas semanas
en lo que pasó 28 días en el hospital
fue operado hace un par de meses por una
condición preexistente en el corazón él
salió de la clínica se dijo que seguía
mejorando ese estado de salud pero se ha
hecho hoy este anuncio repito no se han
dado mayores detalles sobre las causas
de la muerte del duque el duque
cumpliría 100 años el próximo 10 de
junio 73 de estos casado con la reina
isabel a jefe de estado del reino unido-
felipe de edimburgo como dice es el rol
que tuvo en la familia real podría
decirse según los expertos puede
encargarse de las labores más domésticas
isabel segunda la reina la monarca
británica encargada de las funciones de
liderar el estado británico tuvo que
ocuparse entonces de estas labores
mientras su esposo se encargó como le
digo de los labores más domésticas de la
educación por ejemplo de sus hijos de
sus cuatro hijos
qué más se puede decir sobre la vida del
príncipe louis a la relación a lo mejor
que tenía con los británicos como bien
lo decía el primer ministro boris
johnson que pues dejó inspiración en
varias generaciones como era la relación
con el público
la relación del duque de edimburgo
podría decirse que tuvo luces y
oscuridad es porque el duque fue
criticado en muchas ocasiones por su
amor muy en negro podría describirse
porque hacía bromas que para muchas
personas eran consideradas racistas el
duque de edimburgo se alejaba de ese
carácter tan polite de de guardarse los
sentimientos el duque decía básicamente
lo que pensaba sin medir las
consecuencias así que eso a muchas
personas no les gustaba pero por otro
lado el duque ha sido fundamental para
la monarquía británica por una sencilla
razón raúl el duque fue la roca fue el
apoyo fue el sostén de la reina isabel
como digo ella se encargó de las
funciones o se ha encargado de las
funciones de liderar este país mientras
que su esposo se encargó de las labores
domésticas pero el duque también a lo
largo de todos estos años él se encargó
de labores sociales puedo decirles que
en el 2017 se retiró de las labores
públicas a los 96 años pero fue
de 800 organizaciones de caridad y
también más de 600 en todo el mundo una
de las más destacadas y queridas aquí en
el reino unido es el premio duque de
edimburgo que se da a los estudiantes de
los colegios en este país por cumplir
metas así que muchos niños son felices
de llevar ese galardón en sus vidas el
premio duque de edimburgo